we're on problem 221
and let's see they have
see is all of that in the denominator
well i guess it is see they wrote one
over and i'll write the way they did it
one over and then they have this
you know what i i think it's gotta be
one plus
i think it's one plus the way they wrote
it is weird one plus
one
plus
over one plus one third this looks a lot
like another problem that we did but
anyway i'll do this one
so let's see
if we do one plus one third that's three
thirds plus one third so that's four
thirds so then that turns into
four thirds
one one plus
one over that and then you have one plus
that
and so that this equals one plus
one over
one plus what's one over four thirds
well that's the same thing as one
divided by four thirds the same thing as
one times three fourths so that's equal
to three fourths
and what's one plus three fourths well
that's four fourths plus
three fourths
right
4 4 so that's 7 4. so then that becomes
1 plus
over
7 4
which is equal to 1 plus 4 over 7
and that equals 7 over 7 plus 4 over 7
is equal to 11 over 7. and that's choice
d
the way they wrote it was weird they
wrote it like this 1 plus down here but
i assume that this is what they wanted
what i originally had done problem 222
and the rectangular coordinate system
above well let me draw it
that's the y-axis
that's the x-axis
y
x
and they have a point out here called
point p and they say that's at four x
equal four y equals zero and the
rectangular coordinate system above if
point r not shown
lies on the positive y axis it lies
someplace over here and the area of
triangle orp so this is point o
and r is going to be some place on this
is 12 what is the coordinate of the
point r so the coordinate of the point r
let's just call it
well the x value is going to be zero
right unless this y value is let's just
call it i don't know let's call it
let's call it x no it's called y that's
a better that's a better variable name
for the y value
so they essentially want to know what
the area of this triangle right here is
or actually they want to know what y is
given that the area of that triangle
these tell us is 12 the area of this
triangle is 12. so what's the area of
this triangle it's the base
times the height times one half the base
is 4 right this is x is equal to 4 so
it's 4
times the height well the height is
going to be y right
because the coordinate of r is zero
comma y so four times y
times one half if you don't do the one
half you're getting the area of the
whole rectangle is equal to the area of
the triangle is equal to 12. so you get
2y is equal to 12
y is equal to 6. so the coordinate of r
is 0 comma 6.
and that is choice oh they just x they
just ask what is the y coordinate of
point r so that's 6 and that's choice b
problem 223
car a is 20 miles behind car b
so let me see if i could draw that
so this is a this is b
and it's 20 miles behind it i don't know
if that's relevant
which is traveling in the same direction
or
along the same route as car a car a is
traveling at a constant speed of 58
miles per hour so car a
is at 58 miles per hour and car b is
traveling at a constant speed of 50
miles per hour
fair enough how many hours will it take
for car a to overtake and
drive eight miles ahead of car b
so
essentially how much to so they they
don't want just car a to catch up they
want car a to catch up and
go and go ahead eight miles right and
drive eight eight miles ahead so another
way to think about it is
how long will it take for car a to go 28
miles further than car b
right
and the easiest way to think about it is
just what their differential is right
car a is going eight miles an hour
faster than car b so the relative
velocity of a relative to b is eight
miles an hour
right we could say that well i don't
want to use fancy notation but car a if
you're if you're sitting in car b and
you look at car you say oh it's going in
my same direction but it i'm stationary
and it's going at eight miles per hour
eight miles per hour
so the question essentially says if i'm
going eight miles per hour how long does
it take to go 28 miles
right because i have to catch up to 20
miles with b and then i have to go eight
more miles you could you know right you
could just pretend like you are in car b
and you think that you are stationary
you ignore that the fact that the world
is speeding behind you and you just see
car a you say oh car a must be moving at
eight miles an hour
right in the direction at which my car
is pointed
so anyway if you have to go 28 miles
and you're going at eight miles per hour
right distance divided by rate is equal
to time
that's equal to
three
and a half
three and a half hours
which is choice e
next question 224
for the past n days the average daily
production at a company was 50 units so
for n days
unit
per day
average
if today's production of 90s of 90 units
so we have 90 units and that raises the
average to 55 units per day what was the
value of n
okay so the old average would have been
n
times 50
divided and this is kind of obvious
divided by n
is equal to 50
right
now if i want to average in this 55
what happens is
i get to
n
times
right that's the sum of the n days
before the sum of the total production
for the n days before
and what i want to do is i want to add
the production for today and that is 90
plus 90
and now i'm going to divide by n plus 1
days right
n plus 1 days and now the average the
new average is 55.
so now we just have to solve this for n
so let's see what we can do we get
doing a different color we get 50 n
plus 90 is equal to multiply both sides
by n plus one 55
and
plus
55.
so let's subtract 50 n from both sides
you get 90
is equal to 5n
plus 55
subtract 55 from both sides see 55
that's 35
is equal to 5n
n is equal to
7 and that's choice e
problem 225
okay they write
x plus 1
over
x minus 1
squared and they say if x does not equal
x does not equal 0
and x does not equal 1 x does not equal
1. that's good because if x equals 1
we'd be dividing by 0 here
and if x is replaced by 1 over x
everywhere in the expression above so
x is replaced with 1 over x everywhere
in the expression above then the
resulting expression is equivalent to
well i don't know let's just do it
so if we get 1 over x we're just
replacing x with 1 over x
plus 1
over 1 over x minus 1 quantity
squared
and that equals let's see this is the
same thing as 1 over x plus x over x
right
1 is the same thing as x over x and this
this one is the same thing as x over x
right that's an x over x so then this
equals
1 plus x
over x
over
1 minus x over x
everything squared
and this inside of the the brackets
that's the same thing as 1 plus x over x
instead of being divided by this we
could multiply by the reciprocal times
x over 1 minus x i just reciprocated
this and multiplying and now and this is
all in still in the squared now these
x's cancel out and lo and behold we get
1 plus x
over one minus x
squared
which is the same thing as
x plus one
let's think about it x plus one over
well over one minus x
squared
and let's see that's not one of the
choices
right
but let's think about it one minus x
that's the same thing as so let me
rewrite it
this is the same thing as x plus 1
divided by now this 1 minus x is the
same thing as x minus 1
times negative 1 right
times negative 1.
and we're going to square all of this
well this over here this is the same
thing as x plus 1 over x minus 1
squared
times 1 over negative 1 squared right if
you take the square of a product
right you could view this you could this
is the same thing as that times 1 over
negative 1.
so that turns into this and this
obviously if i'm squaring another number
this just becomes 1. so i'm left with x
plus 1 over x minus 1 squared
and that's exactly what we started off
with and that's choice a
and that's the trick to realize
that this is just a negative of x minus
one and you could take a negative one
out but we're going to square it anyway
so it's going to turn it back positive
next question
and choice e actually that when they
tempt you by taking the negative outside
but you can't take the negative outside
the square you're squaring it so the
negative will disappear
anyway problem 200 oh i'm all out of
time see you in the next video